She's insane.
How much did she bet on a pig?
If I'm second place.
I'm out 10 million yen.
Well, that doesn't matter.
I can get that amount of money.
The bigger problem is the fact
that she disobeyed me.
I'll make sure she never fights back.
Congratulations, everyone.
All ten turns are complete.
I will now announce the results.
The winner...
is Mary Saotome,
with 166 million yen.
Second place is Nanami Tsubomi,
with 92 million yen.
Hey, wait!
Third place is Yumeko Jabami...
- Hey!
- ...with 74 million yen.
- Fourth place is Jun Kiwatari...
- Wait! You're getting this wrong!
You're not making a damn bit of sense!
The results are correct.
Like hell they are!
I've got five Jabami chips!
That's way above 58 million on its own!
Saotome, it's rude to laugh too much.
I didn't think it would work so well!
Part of it was luck, but a lot of it
was thanks to your acting!
Yeah? Thanks!
You still didn't figure it out?
Do the math.
Two sets of chips
have their values swapped, right?
The chips?
JABAMI
God, you're slow at math.
All right, I'll tell you.
Yumeko's and mine are switched.
Yumeko's chips are worth 5 million yen,
and mine are worth 310 million.
See? The math works, right?
Don't be stupid. You can't just...
It was in the rules, right?
You can write your own amount of debt.
In other words, Yumeko only reported
5 million of her 310 million yen debt.
And I have 50 million in debt,
but I reported it as 310 million.
You said on your application that you took
10 million from a friend, right?
We did the same thing.
You weren't the only liar.
An acquaintance of mine
should be getting the money now.
Suzui, message from the student council.
What the hell is this?
The rest was simple.
I received a board
that read "310 million yen,"
and Yumeko got one
that said "50 million."
So, we just switched.
And then, how strange...
The values of our chips were switched.